caminando por la calle te aborda una
persona diciendo rápido ayúdame necesito
saber si el 2943 es divisible entre 9 y
tú conoces una técnica rápida para saber
si un número es divisible entre 9 que
consiste en sumar los dígitos del número
o sea dos más nueve más 4 + 3 y si el
resultado de la suma de los dígitos de
este número es un número múltiple o
divisible entre 9 entonces el número es
divisible entre 9 por lo que haces dos
más nueve es 11 415 más 3 18 y 18
definitivamente es un número divisible
entre 9 por lo que 2 mil 943 es un
número divisible entre 9 si tienes dudas
puedes volver a aplicar la misma técnica
al resultado en este caso es 18 sumar
sus dígitos
y ver si el resultado es divisible entre
9 o sea si toma el 18 tengo uno más 8
189 y definitivamente el 9 es un número
divisible entre 9 así que uno ha salvado
una vida y los problemas que tiene esta
persona y te vas muy contento un rato
después te preguntas es si esta técnica
funciona para cualquier número aunque se
ve claro que esta técnica no funcionaría
para ver si un número es divisible entre
7 menos entre 8 o entre 17 y esta
técnica que tú ya sabes funciona para
saber si un número es divisible entre 9
y 3 el último caso lo vamos a ver
próximamente en un vídeo y piensas que
es buena idea entender qué es lo que
está pasando entonces vamos a tomar al
2943 y lo vamos a reescribir de esta
manera o sea el 2
está en la posición de los millares lo
voy a reescribir como 2 está siendo x
luego el 9 está en la posición de las
centenas lo voy a describir como 9 x
el siguiente que es el 4 que está
este el 4 que está en las decenas que
voy a describir como 4 por 10 y en las
unidades el 3 lo va a dejar tal
ahora lo siguiente que observamos es que
2943 es equivalente o lo mismo que tener
dos por mil 32 mil más 9% que es 900 más
40 que es 4 por 10 3
el siguiente paso va a ser tomar estos
números el 1000 el 100 y el 10 y
reescribir los como un 1 más algo que es
divisible entre 9 o sea el me lo puedo
reescribir como uno más 999
sí verdad es lo mismo ahora el 100 lo
puedo reescribir como uno más 99 99 1 es
100 es exactamente lo mismo sólo estoy
reescribiendo el 10 lo voy a describir
como uno más 9 y entonces ahora
continuamos con este asunto
dos por mil es lo mismo que escribir
todos que está siendo x 1 999 9%
es lo mismo que escribir 9 que está
siendo x 1 + 99 luego el 4 por 10 es lo
mismo que 4 por 1 + 9 y el 3 de las
unidades lo va a dejar exactamente
entonces yo sólo estoy reescribiendo las
cosas de acuerdo bueno ahora vamos a
distribuir o sea 2 x 1 es 2
más
2 está multiplicando a 999
luego tengo más
el 9 por 1 que es este que está aquí
9 x 19 + 9 que está multiplicando al 99
99 más 4 que está más 4 que está
multiplicando al 14 por unos 4 más el 4
que está multiplicando al 94 por 9 más
las unidades que teníamos estrés
muy bien
ahora voy a reagrupar para que lo veamos
más claro lo voy a poner en este naranja
voy a agrupar los términos que están
siendo multiplicados este que está aquí
este que está aquí
y este que está aquí
entonces ahora después escribí con
naranja para que se vean más claros 2
por 999 es el primero que tengo luego
tengo más
9 por 90 y 99
99 luego tengo más 4 x 9
simplemente estoy reagrupando y ahora
voy a reescribir los que aquí tengo los
activos que suman un 2 que está aquí
porque sumarle el 9 que está aquí más
tengo que sumarle el 4 que está aquí
4 y luego el 3
muy bien entonces lo que tenemos que
analizar ahora es si está
parte de aquí los términos que están en
naranja si cada uno de ellos es
divisible entre 9 obviamente si son
divisible en 39 su suma será divisible
entre 9 pero vamos uno por uno aquí yo
tengo un número que está siendo
multiplicado por 999 pero 999 si es
divisible entre el 9 así que el
resultado de este producto será
divisible entre el 9 y luego el
siguiente tengo 99 que es divisible
entre 9 que multiplica cualquier número
no importa cuál hay aquí así que el
resultado del producto será divisible
entre 9 y luego éste de acá pues es 9
por 4 en este caso el número que sea
pues también será divisible entre 9
entonces la suma de estos tres también
es un número divisible entre 9 entonces
todo esto que está de este lado es
divisible
invisible entre 9 perfecto y lo que
tenemos de este lado ya lo habíamos
hecho acuérdense lo que tenemos aquí es
por donde empezamos la suma de estos
números la suma de estos dígitos en este
número es divisible entre 9 así que en
general para revisar si un número es
divisible entre 9 sólo tengo que revisar
que la suma de sus dígitos sea divisible
l
/
9 y con esto hemos terminado